because of Empire which is this  phenomenal okay now that I don't know if  this bugs you or not but I would imagine  wherever you go people call you cookie  like everywhere yeah pretty much  and is that are you cool with that  it's no I mean you know I get it but you  know it's like I'm off I'm not at work  and cookie is work and so when people do  it I like I have this little nervous  twitch  thank you that's why you push me the  other day yeah  I was just trying to be funny with you  push me that now I would think one of  the nice things about doing 30 rock is  that your character was named Tracy  what's that what do you mean to you know  and Lauren wanted me to be Bobo day  what'll you say one of your name Bobo  Jordan I told Laura Michael no you walk  through the airport for the next 15  years that's my car you Bobo  [Laughter]  yeah that's fantastic so they wanted you  to be Bobo and you shut it down  I shut it down that's why my name is  Tracy every character I play Tracy yeah